[موسيقى]
كما تعلمون فان روسيا فككت الاتحاد
السوفيتي وعده دول منحت حريتها بسبب ذلك
ومنها اوكرانيا وكلها كانت جزءا من
الفيدراليه الروسيه لكن ما حدث لاحقا ان
بعض تلك الدول عندما امتلكت حريتها رغبت
بالانضمام الى النيتو المعارض لروسيا
وبالطبع تشعر روسيا بان ذلك خطر يهددها
حيث ان عده دول صافيه سابقه كانت تابعه
لفدراليه روسيا اصبحت اعضاء في التجمع
الغربي هذا التجمع الغربي واداه النيتو تم
احداثه لمجابهه روسيا واعتبارها عدوه لو
كانت هذه الدول بعيده عن روسيا اعتقد ان
موسكو ما كانت لتقوم باي شيء ولكن بحكم
محاذاه اوكرانيا لروسيا وعندما تنضم
اوكرانيا للنيتو فان الخطر يصبح وجوديا
على موسكو لان العدو اصبح على الحدود
المباشره ما يجعلها تشعر بانها غير امنه
لان العدو قريب جدا
[موسيقى]
الامر يتعلق بالاستفزاز فعندما ترغب
اوكرانيا بالانضمام الى النيتو ذلك يعد
استفزازا واضحا لانه تهديد لروسيا بواسطه
قوات
وعندما تستفز فانك تحصل على نتائج سيئه
لذلك اصبحت اوكرانيا جبهه حرب للنيتو من
دون اي ضلوع ميداني لذلك فان اوكرانيا تجد
نفسها اليوم وحيده تعاني ويلت الحرب
وتتكبت الكثير من الخسائر مع مقتل الالاف
من مواطنيها ونزوح وهجره الملايين الاخرين
كما تم قصف عده مناطق منها فوجدت اوكرانيا
نفسها تعاني وتحارب وحدها في الوقت الذي
يزودها النيت بالسلاح والاموال للقتال وفي
النهايه ستجد نفسها مدمره في الوقت الذي
لا يخسر النيت شيئا
[موسيقى]